[Music]
hello
this is Julian Polanco I'm a national
master from the state of Missouri and
today we have viewers Choice so let's
get right into it so here we have with
the white pieces cuz Keshava jindal 19
verses PJ Healy with playing the black
pieces I have I'm I should get a lot of
credit for pronouncing both of those
names but let's just get right into the
chest
so why plays efore c5 this is the
Sicilian defense night of 396 so maybe
blacks trying to play classical
variation or the sveshnikov he doesn't
play maybe d76 just plays nice eServices
this is all fine Bishop b5 this is the
raw soul emo attack so far so good g6 is
one of the main moves here another
another thing that you could do with
black and I've had a lot of experience
in these types of positions with like
I've played this fashion cough in
particular a lot with the black pieces
is you can go ecigs
this is something that been Feingold has
done a lot and if your opponent you know
castles you can go 97 and you can follow
up with a six so that you don't get
these double pawns on c6 this is a
potential idea that black could go for
instead black just goes g6 claiming that
white isn't really threatening to take
on c6 yet if black were to play
something like a sex in this position
then obviously why it would take on c6
and give black some structural damage
but
and particular the pollen c-5 could be
subject to attack maybe with d3 and
Bishop III but if if black continues to
do and develop as pieces like with g6
immediately then Bishop c6 isn't
actually a threat yet so why just why
just castles he's waiting for a black to
put the question to the bishop in order
to resolve this this tension Bishop g7 C
3 so white with this move c2 c3 it's
kind of indicating that he wants to play
the move d2 to d4
it seems very fine up to now perfect
game I think there's lots of high-level
games here I'm not sure but I can't
imagine there wouldn't be and here
Knight to f6 and at this moment actually
I was I'm mildly surprised because from
my understanding I I've played this a
lot with white 2 with with the white
pieces blacks usual counter play in this
type of position is the force White's
pawn says something like d4 and d5 and
then undermined it with some of like F
sex and I'm not entirely sure if the
knight wants to be on f6 or h6 because
potentially if the Knights on h6 you can
play something like f6 and knight Knight
to Knight to f7 so maybe night h6 is is
something that's interesting in this
position worth some explore exploration
because if you go d4 I think you can
just take you know you can even like
play something like this or well
actually this is a little bit too much
because you can take and take on a fight
but d5 and if something if some position
like this or arrives on the board then
you can easily see how black is counter
play without six a night or so but
Knight of 6 is a very normal move as
well it's just something that you have
to take into consideration
b5 and Knight to g4 so what what would
you guys do the audience where would you
put your knight what do you do you like
what black is done to go to g4 and
target the e5 pawn do you want to put on
d5 what are your thoughts just in
general
why cláudio with the right answer
right yeah because it's very easy to
defend the center here right like you
just go d4 and the pawn on e5 is is
sufficiently defended like there's
nothing that black can really do to
further attack this this point so
because usually in chess I'm from like
pawn structure so you want to attack the
base of the pawn structure right and the
base of the pawn structure is actually
d4 because like let's say take sake this
is the base right
it is defending the e5 pawn the fact
that the pollen c5 exists means the d4
is the base so I don't I don't think
that the 94 is a good idea because
you're not attacking the base of the
pawn structure you're attacking the head
of the pawn structure right so that's
that's not really something that you
would hope to undermine I mean maybe f6
but that comes with its pluses and
minuses and if you were going to play
like this you may as well play 96 and
the opening inside and I know sometimes
but yeah I think 95 is correct because
well the Knights centralized on d5 let's
say you castle and you can sorry
you can play D d7 to d6 and then I saw
better in the center than it is on G 4G
forced kind of loose so I think 95 is a
is a potential improvement in this type
of position well I think so there's a
general rule for attacking so d4 right
this was played in the game I believe
yeah
after 94 you're not gonna win on on this
side with black right well white has too
many defenders usually in order for an
attack to work you need to win by like
two two attackers so why does one two so
which this is a thing you can do do in
your own games just see you divide the
board into four quadrants right like
sorry like this right and if you wanted
some kind of attack to succeed you need
to be winning by two White has one one
defender right I control the square
square the square right well mostly
these two squares and the square the
Cain is also a defender
right so that's defender number two and
this is defender number three you have
one attacker yeah so obviously if white
needs to defend he's going to be able to
defend right you're not going to be
stronger on that side so any attack that
you're going to you know perform over
there is not going to work so probably
you should try to play on the side where
you're stronger and well the side where
black could potentially be stronger is
actually the center right because
there's a lot of tension here and you
can kind of break down the structure
because white doesn't have a lot of
pieces in the center yet but black does
that's something that he said like black
sacrificed pawns in the center four
pieces right so he has lots of pieces
attacking the center except for maybe
the knight on g4 so he can potentially
attack in the center that's what that's
what blacks goal should be which is why
in these positions usually blacks attack
in the center with either f6 or d6 so
that's why Knight g4 is potentially a
little iffy just because you're not
going to really win on the side it's not
it's a losing battle so anyway so
hopefully any does that clear d4 takes
takes a6 so black puts the question to
the bishop I I don't like I don't like
what black is done like the
transformation of the position is
actually kind of severe how white
handles this position is very
instructive actually so blacks knight on
g4 is a tactical liability it's
undefended right so you could
potentially see like pretend the bishops
on c4 then Bishop F 795 would win right
so you have you you already have ideas
in the air just based on the fact that
the nice misplaced but what white just
continues to develop his pieces he takes
on c6
he doesn't want to go up the initiative
and black takes with the b-pawn which is
probably wrong at this stage I would
take back with the D pawn because I want
my knight to be defended take him back
with the be pawns kind of greedy like
black wants everything black wants to
because the advantage of playing the
Sicilian the reason why you would play
this
Elena's because you want more center
points right so black wants to maintain
his to center pawns which isn't even
true because white also has two Center
pawns by virtue of not playing the open
Sicilian so I think that what black
should do is just realize okay I'm worse
I should take back with my D pawn maybe
I can play for the d5 square I can put
my bishop on e6 my knight on f5 and take
things from there
maybe I Morris maybe I'm not maybe I'll
make Oh eyes but I think that this is
the better way to go after B takes white
white kicks the night I would not have
done this I think that you can play h2
h3 whenever you want I feel like it's
better just to develop your pieces
immediately with something like Knight
to c3 and then continuing maybe with d4
d5 White House is a development
advantage so we want to try to open the
position up I will play d5 after we play
h3 but first I want to get ready for
that like maybe I'll bring more pieces
and with Bishop g5 or Bishop f4
something of this nature anyway white
plays h3 night h6 Knight c3 and yeah I
mean it's very clear I think everybody
in this audience would agree almost
everybody that they they would rather
have white right like you have more you
you have the center all of your pieces
are out your castled
like white white is has demonstrated
that he has a very good chess foundation
right like he was taught by somebody
good you know you're supposed to develop
your pieces in the center you're
supposed to Castle White's done
absolutely nothing wrong and well black
has wasted some time I this move ate a
76 it's just something you you cannot
play in these types of positions white
very often times will take on c6 Volvo
'ln Tara Lee but this is this is I think
fundamentally where where black is
already gone wrong a 76 you just cannot
waste this this much time in the open
so anyway returning returning to the
position black plays Bishop b7 which is
another really greedy move I understand
what black wants to achieve it's not to
say the blacks a bad a bad player
anything like maybe even like his
understanding of chess might be greater
than whites that's very possible this is
one of those instances where I mean why
does done nothing wrong right he has all
of his pieces in the center but black
understands that he has two bishops and
eventually if he manages to play c6 to
c5 his bishop will be very open the
problem is is that he's not addressing
his his Kings side or the the immediate
you know
threats the white could pose to him he
he really needs to castle right now he
needs to castle and he and it it's not
even clear if the bishop is better on b7
or say at five or six something like
that so I would Castle I would play d6
or f6 and I would hope for the best
Bishop d7 is another inaccuracy Knight
to e4 and Knight to e4 basically
preventing any kind of c-5 c5 is out of
the question now
you could argue for c5 here right like
if white takes then you have some
compensation although every single
person in the world should play the move
d4 d5 instead of taking on c5 but 94
basically just says no you're not going
to you're not gonna play C 5 and if
black castles here which I don't think
he played yeah he played rook b8
then why it will play something maybe
like night c5 and that night on c5 looks
pretty strong to me so
black-clad rook b8 and white played
Bishop g5 it's fine so far so good
Knight of five so black black recognizes
that his knight on f5 is I'm sorry his
Iron Age six is very bad so he wants to
put her on a 5g for like whoa what's
that right like you're voluntarily
weakening York inside but g4 is a very
strong move because white recognizes I'm
Knight a5 is a mistake you cannot you
you cannot play chess like this right
you need to develop your pieces you need
to have your fair share of the center
and black black spends a lot of time
with his knights and his pawns in this
game
what black should do is he should castle
after after night of five chief
yeah but I have each sex right or do I
not or f6 something like that this is
this is this is what Claudius 20 not
aged six I mean this is really bad to
write blacks position isn't good maybe
this was way he was avoiding anyway -
but yeah you can play like this yeah but
this is this is the worst position ever
so it's not it's not good there's good
and there's not good this isn't good all
right
yeah so castles is bad night of five is
bad already
Wyatt wait is demonstrated that he's
very strong g4 and here 96 i I think
okay what would the audience play here
Claudia is not allowed to answer
actually Claudia's a lot to answer what
would you play right so the so your
first suggestion I'll deal with your
first suggestion I think if you do
something like rook c1 or queen d3 or
something like you know like it those
are all fine most right there you know
like increasing the pressure but I don't
think they're like the most critical
Queen d2 is critical because you are
threatening to win on the spot right so
after Queen d2 you're threatening to
take on h6 and the game could just be
over so let's let's look at this one
first the other moves will look at later
right so Queen d2 Queen d2 threatens to
take on age sex and if the knight moves
then obviously you're better but what
are you going to do here
there's an idea so what what it should
be the first thing you look at in this
position it shouldn't be any Queen move
right you can look at Queen moves but
you'd need to identify that black has it
has a problem in the position Claudia
what's the problem
right the be pons pin so 96 as possible
so we can we can take blacks castling
rights away right so I'm not saying this
is good or bad but it is the first thing
you need to look at in the position
because your candidate moves should
include captures and checks yeah so 96
is the first thing you should look at
and then you're like kina fate and you
have to assess this position so whether
you like this position and yes or no
that's fine Queen d2 Queen d2 might be a
better move
I actually think 96 is probably
inaccurate because after keen f8
though though you have essentially made
blacks problems permanent right so now
black will never castle it's not like
he's losing immediately and you you do
have to deal with your d6 night because
white might be threatening some f6 and
winning tonight on d6 yeah so yeah if
you take on d6 then I take on FDA yeah
it's so Queen D Queen d2 is a fine move
right because we're threatening to take
on h6 Oh castles is now out of the
question and if 98 now all we say well
what happens if we play 96 yeah so you
have to look at 96 in every variation
and after 96 King f8 I personally don't
see the immediate win right now maybe
you do and all the power to you but I
think that after 98 what I would
personally do here with with white as I
play this move Queen up for I would play
Queen d2 because I'd force the knight
back to g8 I play Queen up for now now
if if you you know if you're not careful
96 Queen f7 is made right and I've
the basically all of Wight's pieces are
contributing to the position and if you
move away anyway right like somewhere
random maybe I'll go to 96 anyway you
take I take and how are you gonna
respond to this it's unclear so this
would have been very interesting Queenie
to Queen f4 is a very decent plan well
why did is also fine White's very sneaky
he plays Queen b3 the same idea now
there's ninety six point f7 right I
don't know if I like this one as much
because black can still Castle kingside
well it certainly certainly white has
demonstrated some form of patience
Bishop a eight is also a very sneaky
move how many of you would play ninety
six here Claudia is not allowed to
answer you would not play Knight d6
or you would
right but let's let's assume right it's
a poor assumption but let's assume that
after 96 kenaf aid is obligatory right
you would obviously play 96 right
because in queen of sevens maid
so the question here becomes is do you
how much material what's the material
balance after 96 eeeh
he takes d6 right so Bishop a it's very
sneaky
this dude's a sneaky guy 96 is a mistake
because after takes what it's probably
gonna take and then black takes white
takes black takes white takes and we've
arrived to some position where I I don't
know what the evaluation is and that's
not good because we were much better
with white and now I'm not sure who was
better so well the bishops not trapped
right because after after 96 eat takes
takes takes takes here I can just move
my King protecting my bishop with my
rook or I can move my bishop and attack
your work and then move my king
whichever order you prefer actually this
might be a little no it's not
never mind I was thinking for a second
that this was this was something but I
obviously just take the word sorry rook
a 7
wait you were k7 here yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay I agree with that
so Kinsey Sarah yeah oh no but Brooke k7
anyway no okay but the position you
would never go for this with white
because maybe why it's better maybe he's
not right like even if you win the pawn
on d6 like this is far from clear
although I would rather be white so 96
was not played waited a lot of patience
and played Queen I 3 now castles would
be unfortunate I think I might do it
anyway because of Asha p7 and this is
working the the Queen and the rook and I
might I might do like this was a blitz
game I might have played this anyway
just because at least I've castled and
I'm not going to get mated but that's
neither here nor there
so black decided to play off 6 never
play offs away it's nuts not my rule
anyway after f6 black is totally totally
lost I don't know what black should do
in this position
maybe Queen b3 Queen a3 refutes this
this whole this whole thing it's very
possible
I mean after Queen b3 what black should
definitely castle which is what black
should have done the entire game so if
you're taking notes at home castling is
good all right Queen a3 except here then
never Castle alright it's really
confusing and chess is hard f6 takes
Bishop takes how anybody who's not
Claudio what would you do here
you what would you do here and if paan
takes
oh you wanted to take h6 ah it's very
good yeah this one's a piece immediately
you are better than the players in these
games mm-hmm
actually unclear maybe what white did
was better but yeah this is this very
good you take on f6 and you've removed
the defender of h6 by the way that night
that moved around it's constant tactical
issue just drops off the board here yeah
it's very good it's very safe Bishop f6
is the kind of thing it's it's more
greed greedy although I guess black I
mean probably this is better anyway I
mean blacks position is so horrible that
Bishop takes pawn takes Knight d6 just
wins
Lexie nice to step into unfortunate
unfortunate miss King g7 so white is
threatening rook to e8 right which I'd
probably once again allow somehow just
so that I could get out of whatever
nonsense that I'm in I'll show the end
very briefly g5 I don't understand the
point of g5 honestly what what's the
point somebody help me out why is why is
this not good no
why would white do this I don't get it
right whites techniques a little suspect
right like you have two options to win a
piece here right like just take on age
six or you can do what you did right
play 96 the night of five highly
recommended or you can do this this is
fine but what is where's chief I don't I
don't understand all right well then
black play night of five takes takes
rookie seven and now it's practically
checkmate Queen d6 threatening f7 rook
g8f sevens a threat so g6 rooked you won
c5 and I will allow our fine audience to
find mate and three except Claudia
actually that's just made into but find
the mate than that find the mate that
the player played not the fastest way to
mate because those two things are
completely different sorry what
yeah it's matin to but find them eight
and three yes what's buddy do you if you
see matin to say it very good and if and
if I move very good no that's checkmate
all right so that's that's what should
be played white shows it and you know
more understanding by playing Rick g6
suffering right
you want your opponents to suffer HG
Queen f4 and then mate so that was this
game all right so onto our next Travis
I mean game a few moments that I
criticized but overall what why that's
kind of like you know well I think both
players were like fourteen hundred or
something like that but it looks like
one player is significantly stronger
than the other and those are always very
instructive game white plays d4 d5
Bishop f4 the London system something
that I will talk about in a future
opening lecture Bishop f5 which is fine
Knight f3 Knight of 6 e 394 so this
violates an opening principle you what
opening principle does this violate not
to put you on the spot or anything
do you know correct
you don't know all right now I'm just
kidding yes yes that's correct in the
you know the opening principle
I mean you've demonstrated from previous
questions that your strong player right
so I don't know but don't move the same
piece twice in the opening it's not a
good idea
because if you're moving you know one
piece over and over and over again and
your opponent develops their entire army
then you're gonna you're gonna have some
problems
so 94 question mark Bishop d3 save
white's developing all you know like
every move a different piece yeah eat
692 Bishop b4 Bishop before is not a
good move because why well white played
a three but in the London system in
general I think this idea was based on
his tactics which is incorrect that it
doesn't work but usually when this move
is played right so let's pretend the
bishop moves away right and then white
plays a3 in this position black is a
very thematic tactic which is knight on
e4 takes f2 right and this is a fork
right I'm working the the bishop and the
Queen after Akeem takes bishop takes
what black is 1 upon 4 basically nothing
right so this is the tactic that the
that black hopes the play but after c3
what we might notice is that the bishop
on before is hanging so if I played c3
and black takes on c3 with the night we
take back the bishops also hanging or
you take on f2 either case night of 2
KNF to Bishop d3 we just take on before
and white has more pieces and therefore
stands better if you're taking notes at
home having more pieces is better write
that down all right a through is played
instead I guess there's nothing wrong
with that I would play see once again I
would play this this move because in
general
well I would want the bishop to move
away somewhere stay here and then maybe
I'd want to target e4 with something
like Quincy - maybe I want to take out
five minutes no what what white did is
also good a three so White's encouraging
blacks take everything on d2 which I
think black should do right if you're
you know behind in development you
should probably trade pieces so that
your opponent has less pieces to meet
you with it's my advice after Bishop to
a5 before was played here black has an
interesting opportunity but is to play
Knight c3 but the problem with something
like Knight c3 is of white just moves
his queen and then he takes enough v and
blacks and significantly worse Bishop e6
I'll black significantly worse anyway
because what does the bishop on b6 do
right what's it looking at all right I
mean last game I talked about targeting
the head of a pawn chain I don't think
there's ever been a stronger head of
upon ch2 chain than d4 right this is
something that I would not attack with
with a bishop I mean c5 not this should
be six anyway takes takes 95-97
this is very controversial I would never
take on e4 I would just castle
I would castle I would put my knight on
e5 and I would play the move f2 to f3
something like that Bishop takes pawn
takes Knight e5 1997 c4 and this is the
correct plan if you're gonna play like
this so at least white is very
consistent he's trying to play against
the bishop which I totally understand
c5 94 and well white has fully justified
his decision I think the void stands
significantly better castles g4 this is
something I would never do I'm winning
on one side right so I don't I don't
know g4 is a bad move but I don't know
if I would make it complicated like g4
seems to me like a move that aims for
complications when White has a very
clear strategic advantage
already he doesn't need to to play for
anything else all you have to do is
because black is essentially down a
piece right you you play with your extra
piece I would take on d7 play like 95
will you if we go into some ending then
I'll be significantly better the bishop
on F fit on f5 isn't exactly black
stream bishop either so white just has
to better minor pieces against two
weaker minor pieces so white should why
should probably just trade the knight on
these out but g-49 take c5 black sorry
white just takes back on a5 Bishop g6
and h4 now H sex this is a huge
strategic mistake you never want this
pawn structure right this is a structure
you never want the e6 pawn is is doubled
and these are two doubled isolated pawns
which are subject to attack this is not
this is not playable for for black what
white did is also good although I would
have just played Knight takes c6 I think
what black should do is play the move f6
because well did I just make that the
main line that would suck oh well
whatever
96 takes in contrast to the previous
position where we had double pawns right
where we forced white to take on g6 now
we can support our structure with the
move FF 6 to f5 black might be worse
black might be I mean actually already
here I wouldn't play f5 immediately I
just put my Queen on d5 and claim the
you know like eventually I'm getting out
like I'll play Queen d5 and Bishop 2 to
be a something something like this
because fundamentally white doesn't want
to trade pieces when he has a space
advantage so after after Knight takes g6
like unless unless you're getting
something very concrete after h6 which
was played in the game I would play
nitrogen it takes g6 because that's a
very permanent advantage right that's
something that's not going to go away
whereas after f6 I'm not sure if white
would have actually played Knight takes
to sex
okay-y plays g5 black plays h5 so now I
would definitely take on g6 this is more
justification my bishop on e5 is going
to be a monster so well that's what
white does Queen to c2 attacking me for
Queen d5 Bishop takes c7 yes so this is
exactly what what what black should do
this what Black has done he's played
queen defy this is very instructive now
it might seem to you that the e4 pawn is
weak and it's doubled and it's isolated
but if that e4 pawn disappears White has
an uncontested center right so you
protecting losing the c7 pawn is the
lesser of two evils after rook c8 which
is a good move black is at least active
so he has a lot of strategic weaknesses
in fact I don't know if I mean it's very
clear that white is strategically better
to strategically winning it's in that
that's the margin that's why it's
playing for but white plays in this mode
is this a good move or a bad move
nobody Claudio is definitely not a lot
to answer
well what I mean
Bishop d6 would it isn't like this is an
outpost straight it's an alpha square
like you can understand the rationale
right it's you know in my opponents
territory I'm preventing the rook and
the Queen's coordination the Queen can't
go back yes it's a bad move why very
good yes you you have rightly noticed
that the Queen on c2 is undefended yeah
so now we can take on d6 and as you
mentioned if white takes back rook takes
c2 and black emerges a piece of the good
very keen tactical I alright alright so
yeah
white white lost this is by the way this
is you know this is why chess is so hard
you can outplay your opponent the entire
game right like black was getting
outplayed this entire game and then you
make one mistake in the game can be over
right like Marrero in any game where
that can happen you know if you're up
like a hundred points and and something
then you know okay never mind
doesn't matter Bishop d6 is a huge
mistake and black doesn't seize his
opportunity he plays rook to d8
if I were playing you he would have lost
but lucky for white rook d8 and now
white notices that his bishops hanging I
think that psychologically it's really
hard to give away your queen that's why
he didn't think that this was possible
what I think that probably what the
reason why black plate that's a bad move
if black played the move rook d8
because he wanted to take on d6 because
it's easier to give away a rook than it
is to give away a queen so you just
don't look you like you look at the
bishop and you lose you see that the
bishops protected by the pawn and you're
like well I have a queen it's silly for
me to give away Queen it's just you need
to see one step farther than in fact
White's Queen is also hanging so I I
feel like psychologically well I I think
the reason why black black didn't play
Queen date it takes d6 is purely
psychological
rook d8 Bishop to e5
be six in okay to be fair if white
didn't play if Y didn't play the move
Bishop d6 and just blunder everything
away then I would say what black did is
totally totally correct this is how you
play against somebody who who already
has all the strategic pluses you try to
get counter play you try to make
complicated you put both your works and
on the most active squares you play b6
and you hope for the best I mean you
know if you're if you're lost right then
it it doesn't matter what you do if you
win right you know everything's correct
at that point so like it doesn't matter
if the computer says you're like minus 2
and then you take the position from like
minus 2 where everything your opponent
does is still minus 2 to minus 4 where
there's only like one thing that your
opponent can do that's where it's like
minus 4
anyway castles was played which is a
mistake because of this and what would
what would you guys do with the black
pieces and if pawn takes
correct yeah so Bishop takes pawn takes
Queen Tate and I don't even know if
black is worse
he might be better already white skins
pretty weak right if you can imagine a
queen arriving to some dangerous square
like h3 or g4 and that could be lights
out right
I'm bare minimum it's a perpetual so and
imagine if some some rook arrives over
here or in any number of things that
could happen White's King is feeling
very unsafe whereas though black has is
compromised structure right he is the
only one that can play 401 at this point
in my opinion rook to d1 rook takes rook
takes rook c5 white plays Queen a4 it's
very important that you try to get
activity and here what black should do
this is a terrible move and I would
never consider it and this is um this is
one of those things that low rate of
players like to do low rate of players
really really like to make one move
threats right because if your opponent
doesn't see it then you win right now
one move threats are great when they
improve your position yeah so if you
have a move that makes a threat and it
also makes your position better there's
very I mean assuming you don't have a
better move then that's the move that I
would almost always play right but rook
a five attacks the Queen right like what
are you hoping for that your opponent
doesn't see that their Queens hanging
like the rook on 85 is so much worse
than c5 like what I was told something
by Ben Feingold when I was like 1700 and
he basically he told me that if I stop
making one move threats now my one move
threats were more like a little bit more
sophisticated it wasn't like oh I attack
your ear your queen it was like maybe
some like cheapo fork or something right
then then I would I would break mm right
actually I actually really believe in
that advice like I think that a lot of
low rated players suffer from
from making needless one move threats
and Roque five is one of those moves I
really don't like it
Queen de8 keen to h7 and black can
resign right the that's just mate this
is a mating construction in the only way
you counter this is if you have activity
imagine the rook we're on c5 as opposed
to a five right like if the rooks on c5
you wouldn't be like you wouldn't say oh
well this is clear because maybe there's
some nonsense going on in the back rank
I mean like the white is still
completely winning because black doesn't
have anything immediate but you had a
move right like whites threatening to
win with Queen a4 right so what you do
you go here so whites threatening to
when you threatened to win so they go
check and they go here and I'm draw what
draw I mean like the black can claim
this draw a few one store he can play
for Maine it's not it's not clear also
also you should note that I can take
this one and like if anybody is going to
win it's going to be black right so this
would immediately deter white from
playing the move rook to d8 rook to DA
right what it's gonna find something
else to do it maybe even Queen City a
because that makes Quinta g4 all the
more stronger because the rook on d1 is
hanging so yeah that's basically
basically my advice is for the black
player is like everything you did when
you got a hopelessly lost should like
strategically hopelessly lost position
was correct right except for not taking
on d6 and I can understand being bad at
tactics I'm horrible at tactics right so
I mean there are things you can do when
you're bad at tactics so I don't blame
you for not taking on d6 what I do blame
you for is for putting your rook on a
square which is worse just because it
attacked something the rook on a5 does
nothing like pretend white isn't winning
right with Queenie a truck da Queen
before now what do you do what was the
point of rook rook to a5 nothing right
okay so yeah that's that's basically my
advice stop making one move threats and
the white player I'd say you have to I'm
you have to work on your technique
because playing the move Bishop d6 here
is really bad first of all and secondly
okay maybe maybe even like at this
moment since black has not the current
position me would state that the bishops
not going to move right because if the
bishop moves I take h5 if you play off
six I take the bishop so what what's
black going to do you can improve your
position for one more move and then take
on g6 if you want so there are lots of
things that the black could have done
here even something
I'm sorry white like let's say even you
know like we do this I'm not sure this
position what this position is for black
takes takes takes Queen takes e4 this
seems very good for white so I don't
know but even what you got in the game
was very nice I like I think White's
close to winning here like just go to g3
or somewhere normal protect your cane
right and then Castle and try to play
against this Bishop black house
compensation here like it's definite and
the reason why black has compensation is
because earlier instead of just being
strategically better and playing against
the bishop you played moves like g4 and
h4 just don't do that and you'll be fine
and for black I mean it kind of sucks
because black played really well I mean
because I think it like so blacks rated
11:45 right and the reason why he's
rated 11:45 is because he plays moves
but like Bishop before and gets his
Bishop trapped on the side of the board
which I'm sure when he got this position
he wasn't happy right I'm fairly certain
right I mean if he's happy then there's
something else wrong and I you know I
can't I can't deal with that but in in
this position right you black did
absolutely everything correct that he
needed to do in order not to it and
we're on to lose he just happened to
play rock a5 at the end and he lost so
well that was that game so let's move on
to our third and final game which is
between why draw who's apparently rated
twenty three seventy seven which is very
suspicious because I looked at his
profile and all he does is he plays
1400s and unrated games and he loses
half his games okay I don't know either
either it's like his student plane it's
very possible 2377 blitz on chess Kong
like that's like my normal rating is
like 24 something on average right it
was like 23 77 this kid dude is within
the bounds like I will bounce between
this ratings so this dude is in theory
the same strength as me right except if
we look at the game so okay so that we
get to a French Bishop Bishop takes f6
is a sideline which is fine okay I can
understand playing this 92 is really
weird
oops anyway f4 c3 and okay this type of
position it's it's if you want to play
92 you play e5 here 97 and then you play
92 because it's really really silly to
give away the bishop pair and then go
into these really complicated positions
where the where either side can open up
the position at any moment right let go
black can play c5 and take on d4 or f6
and take on e5 the position can become
open really really quickly so you don't
give away your bishops for nothing right
now I know that I know that this
variation is is is semi serious because
white can play something like Queen g4
and get some immediate attack but that's
in play 92 was totally not in the spirit
of this variation 97 is also a little
bit strange I think every strong player
would play c5 here because that puts a
media pressure on the d4 pawn but okay
97 seems fine to me
f4 c5 c3 Queen b6
right Queen d2 takes takes castle so
what black is done is correct blacks
opened up the position for his bishops
he's gonna he's Castle and he's
preparing to play the move f6 but she
does when you have the two bishops you
open up the position black stands
clearly better yeah
g3 was played which is a move I would
never never play I would played in
something like Knights III although here
it's really hard to recommend recommend
moves for white and it's really this is
not a good position
g3 takes takes takes yeah
Bishop d7 all of blacks pieces are on
the correct squares white is not castled
right
white white plays the move a3 right
because he has to he has to worry about
this at some moment yeah I I mean if
this so I'm gonna I'm gonna give him the
benefit of the doubt and say that he
actually got to 2377
on like the real way right and that's
that's that's a stretch but it makes me
feel really sad because I want to think
that I'm you know like I'm capable of
playing better than this so this is very
similar to my skill level so yeah I
don't know like what is what is this 92
and then playing the absolute most
passive variation like the Bishop on on
f1 is so sad and that's why he plays g3
right he plays g3 to play Bishop g2 but
I mean it's already too late you have to
respond to your opponent starts in the
opening you can't just like you're not
playing chess in a vacuum you're playing
with your opponent right so anyway takes
takes takes Bishop d7 a3 rook up 7 it's
totally fine castles rook c8 Knight c3
rook f3 is a great move okay Bishop d3
here Bishop a4 was played I mean these
are all normal moves like I'm like what
what did black do black played rook rook
to f3 because he wants to put more
pressure on c3
right he played Bishop to a four because
he wanted to attack do you wanna I'm not
sure Bishop a4 is the best move but it
does because okay so the nice pinned
obviously so that's not a problem but
what what's basically what's basically
happened is blacks putting more pieces
on that side of the board so he's
preparing to win right black is
preparing to win on the side of the
board and there's not a lot the white
can do to stop that Bishop to g5 is a
very very nice move based on a
distraction thing
so if white takes on g5 right now then
you just take on d3 and there's too much
pressure I mean the d4 pawn is hanging
rook takes c3 is something that you need
to calculate literally every single move
this is probably just lost white went
into panic mode took on aged seven took
on g5 then black took on c3 which is
what you would expect to happen takes
takes rook b2 Kenny one rook c1 and you
have to give away your Queen because
otherwise you know like the Queen's gone
its mate so it's lucky you have your
queen so you can give her away
it's just probably not very yeah i never
mind alright that not appropriate that
jokes not appropriate for this class all
right all right Queen takes d4 I mean
the rest of the game is really silly
like black took all of White's pieces
yeah all right and black won this
somehow because he has more pieces all
right cool
so yeah that was that was viewers choice
any questions about any of the games um
we good or yeah alright well thank you
very much this was Julian pearl echo on
viewers Choice
you
[Music]